.
>> WELCOME BACK, EVERYBODY.
THE PENTAGON HOLDING A PRESS
CONFERENCE RIGHT NOW TO TRY TO
UNWIND IN FIND THE CHAOS IN
AFGHANISTAN IF IT IS POSSIBLE.
WE ARE HORRIFIED BUT WHAT WE'RE
SEEING.
THE KABUL AIRPORT IS BACK UP AN
RUNNING.
3,000 TROOPS ARE HEADED THERE
RIGHT NOW.
I THINK IT SHOULD BE AS HIGH AS
SEVEN IT'S AN UTTER DISASTER IN
AFGHANISTAN.
ANYONE WHO SAYS ANYTHING
DIFFERENTLY IS LYING.
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS REFUSING TO
BACK DOWN.
HE IS TRYING TO JUSTIFY HIS
DECISION THAT ALLOWED THESE
CHAOTIC SCENES TO TAKE PLACE.
>> I STAND SQUARELY BEHIND MY
DECISION.
AFTER 20 YEARS, I HAVE LEARNED
THE HARD WAY THAT THERE WAS
NEVER A GOOD TIME TO WITHDRAW
U.S. FORCES.
IF ANYTHING, THE DEVELOPMENTS O
THE PAST WEEK REINFORCE THAT
ENDING U.S. MILITARY INVOLVEMEN
IN AFGHANISTAN NOW WAS THE RIGH
DECISION.
>> THE PRESIDENT WHO PROMISED T
NOT BLAME OTHERS IS POINTING TH
FINGER AT EVERYONE, BUT HIMSELF.
>> WHEN I CAME INTO OFFICE I
INHERITED A DEAL THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP NEGOTIATED WITH THE
TALIBAN AND.
IT WAS HIS AGREEMENT, U.S.
FORCES WOULD BE OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN BY MAY 1 OF 2021.
AFGHANISTAN POLITICAL LEADERS
GAVE UP AND FLED THE COUNTRY.
THE AFGHAN MILITARY COLLAPSED.
SOME OF THEM WITHOUT TRYING TO
FIGHT.
AMERICANS CANNOT AND SHOULD NOT
BE FIGHTING IN A WAR IN DYING I
A WAR THAT AFGHAN FORCES ARE NO
WILLING TO FIGHT FOR THEMSELVES.
>> THAT WOULD MAKE SENSE IF THA
WAS THE FACT THAT THAT IS NOT
THE FACT.
AFGHANISTAN IS BEING TOO THE
HUMILIATING FALL OF SAIGON.
WE PULLED OUT TECHNICALLY IN 73.
THE SECRETARY OF STATE
DISPENSING SUCH CONSPIRACIES.
THIS IS NOT SAIGON, WE WENT TO
AFGHANISTAN 20 YEARS AGO WITH
ONE MISSION IN THAT MISSION WAS
TO DEAL WITH THE FOLKS WHO
ATTACKED US ON 9/11.
WE HAVE SUCCEEDED IN THAT
MISSION.
BUT TAKE A LOOK AT THESE TWO
PHOTOS.
GETTING A LOT OF ATTENTION ON
TWITTER.
YOU SAW THE OTHER SIDE TOO.
THE RIGHT SHOWING KABUL AND
AFGHANISTAN TODAY.
MANY PEOPLE ARE SAYING THIS THA
SAIGON WAS A LOT BETTER THAN
WE'RE WITNESSING NOW BECAUSE
THIS ISN'T QUITE OVERPAID WHAT
WE'RE SEEING RIGHT NOW AS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
TO HIS IMMENSE CREDIT.
HE WOULD'VE SAID 15 YEARS AGO O
20 YEARS AGO, DON'T TELL ME HE
TELL ME SOMEONE THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT HE BELIEVES.
IF YOU HEAR ABOUT ANY
INTERACTION.
WE HAVE TO PULLOUTS OF
AFGHANISTAN, WE WENT OVER THE
HORIZON WITH ALL THE DEFENSE
APPARATUS.
THE CHOICE WAS TO BECOME BACK I
OR HE IS NOT BEING CANDID.
THAT IS NOT THE CHOICE HE HAD.
TO SAY AL QAEDA WAS NOT A THREA
IN THAT REGION IS NOT RIGHT,
IT'S TO SAY THE WAR ON TERROR
MOVED ON IS NOT CORRECT.
THE FACTS ARE DIFFERENTLY.
DANA, THE SPEECH WENT ON FOR 20
MINUTES.
I REALLY FELT HE MEANT EVERY
WORD OF IT, BUT SADLY, WE ARE
SUFFERING THE CONSEQUENCES OF
THIS THAT ARE GOING TO HURT OUR
REPUTATION OUR NATIONAL SECURITY
.
>> WE DO KNOW THAT HE WENT
EXPLICITLY AGAINST THE ADVICE O
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE, THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE FOR STATE
DEPARTMENT IN ALL OF THE FOREIG
POLICY ESTABLISHMENT WHICH HAS
BEEN VERY MUCH IN JOE BIDEN'S
CAMP.
>> THEY COULDN'T WAIT FOR HIM.
>> I COULD I WANT TO SAY ONE
THING ABOUT THE TRUMP COMPARISO
IN THAT BECAUSE I THINK IT WAS
ABSOLUTELY MISPLACED RIGHT I
THINK THE SPEECH IN SOME WAYS I
YOU WERE GIVING A SPEECH ABOUT
WHEN TO LEAVE, AND WHY TO LEAVE
OKAY, BUT THAT WASN'T THE TOPIC
TODAY.
THERE WASN'T A FAILURE TO SPEAK
FOR THE LAST SIX DAYS IT WAS
ABOUT THE ASPIRATE THEY DECIDED
ON APRIL 14TH THAT THEY WERE
GOING TO LEAVE.
SO YOU DIDN'T HAVE TO NAG THEM
IN SAY THAT YOU WERE GOING TO
PIECES IN YOU'VE GOT A PLAN FOR
THE TROOPS TO GET OUT, RIGHT?
YOU NOT GOING TO DO IT IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE WRITING SEASON.
AFTER ALL, AS HE TOLD HER
SEVERAL TIMES HE HAS THE MOST
EXPERIENCE ON FOREIGN POLICY.
THE U.S. PRESIDENCY HAS EVER
SEEN.
TO THE POINT THAT HE BLAMES
PRESIDENT TRUMP GREAT IT'S VERY
CURIOUS AS WE ALL KNOW WE TALK
ABOUT ALL THE TIME HE SPENDS
EVERY DAY REVERSING DRUMS
DECISIONS.
SOMETIMES KNOWING THAT IT IS
ILLEGAL TO DO SO AND INSULTING
SCHOLARS.
IF THAT'S THE CASE, WHY THEN
DOES HE NOT ACCEPT THE PRESIDEN
DEAL IN TERMS OF GETTING OUT OF
THE IRAN NUCLEAR AGREEMENT?
BECAUSE THE SAME ARGUMENT COULD
BE MADE TOO.
IF BOUND BY THIS AGREEMENT WITH
THE TALIBAN OF ALL PEOPLE, THAT
WAS ONE THING.
BUT PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID WE
WOULD GET OUT.
YOU DON'T KNOW, BUT HERE'S THE
THING.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S PLAN WAS TO B
CONDITIONED BASED IN THE TALIBA
IS THE ONE THAT BROKE THE
CONDITIONS.
THE AFGHAN SECURITY FORCES LESS
TENS OF THOUSANDS.
>> NOT GOOD ENOUGH.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE A
DEMOCRACY.
IT WAS PRESIDENT BIDEN THAT
DECIDED TO END THAT IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE FIGHTING SEASON
WHEN HE KNEW THAT THEY WERE
READY TO ROLL ON IN THERE.
TO BE THE CRITICISM AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS GALLING.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT HE LEAVES
CAMP DAVID AFTER NOT SPEAKING
FOR SIX DAYS TO COME TO THE
WHITE HOUSE TO GIVE A SPEECH FO
SENTIMENTS TO GET BACK ON THE
HELICOPTER IN GO BACK TO CAMP
DAVID AS IF THERE'S NOTHING ELS
TO DO.
>> IT'S ASTOUNDING.
I HEAR THEY HAVE A GREAT GOLF
COURSE.
KENNEDY, WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS,
IT DOESN'T REALLY MATTER, I
THINK IT WAS IN A VERY IMPORTAN
POINT THEY BROUGHT UP.
SHOULD WE STAY, SHOULD WE NOT
STATE IN THEN HOW DID YOU DO IT
VERY PLEASE TELL ME THAT WAS A
HUGE INTELLIGENCE FAILURE.
WHETHER THEY WERE ADVISING EVIL
WHO FOUGHT THOUGHTS, PEOPLE WHO
LOST LIMBS.
THEY ALL KNEW THAT THIS WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN.
THAT JOE BIDEN MADE THE
ASSERTION.
>> THE TALIBAN DOESN'T HAVE AN
AIR FORCE.
IT SO THIS SECURITY FORCES THAT
WE TRY TO, THEY AN AIR FORCE.
SO GUESS WHO HAS AN AIR FORCE
NOW PART TALIBAN ENTERED GUESS
WHO HAS ALL THESE WEAPONS IN AL
THIS INTO A DILIGENT, THE
TALIBAN DOES.
FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN SAYING
FOR A LONG TIME MAYBE WE SHOULD
LEARN THE LESSONS SO WE DON'T
HAVE ANOTHER SAIGON, THIS IS
WHAT HAPPENS.
SOMETIMES GETTING OUT IS JUST A
DANGEROUS AS GETTING IN IN
STAYING IN A FRUITLESS
UNWINNABLE SITUATION FOR TWO
DECADES.
>> I WOULD ADD THIS.
THE CONTRACTORS VOLUNTEERED TO
STAY IN THE MECHANICS IN THE
INSTRUCTORS, SO YOU SAID OKAYS,
WILL BE ABLE TO FIX IT IN COACH
YOU.
THE CONTRACTOR SO YOU KEEP
WRITING THE CHECKS, WILL STAY.
OUR ALLIES WANTED TO STAY.
THEY CANNOT BELIEVE THEY ARE
LEAVING.
THEY WERE SAYING WHY DID WE TRY
TO STAY OURSELVES BECAUSE WE
LOST 400 GUYS.
KNOW YOU MUST HAVE A LOT TO SAY.
I SEE A LOT OF NOTES FOR IT TO
GET I WAS WAITING FOR YOU TO
STOP TALKING.
I SAID THIS BEFORE, WE HAVE BEE
FAR REMOVED FROM THIS TOPIC FOR
QUITE SOME TIME SO IT'S A GOOD
EXERCISE TO THINK ABOUT IT
BEFORE YOU HAVE AN OPINION
ASSIGNED TO YOURSELF I'M NOT
GOING TO REFUSE TO GET VERY
UPSET ABOUT THIS.
AGAIN, MY OPINION HAS BEEN
SUSPENDED ANIMATION FOR PROBABL
SEVEN OR EIGHT YEARS.
WE'VE DONE MORE SEGMENTS ON THE
BACHELOR THEN ON AFGHANISTAN.
THE ARGUMENT ISN'T ABOUT LEAVING
.
WE WANT TO LEAVE.
ITS HOW IS IT DONE.
IT WAS BOTCHED, WE CAN ALL ADMI
THAT.
THERE IS SOMETHING THAT IS
REALLY GALLING IS THAT IT WAS A
SIMPLE EQUATION THAT WE ARE ALL
WORKING ON FOR 20 YEARS.
SOFTWARE EXPERT WHAT IS X?
X IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU LEAV
RIGHT I CAN'T BELIEVE WITH ALL
THESE EXPERTS IN ALL THESE
COMMANDERS IN ALL THESE REALLY
BRIGHT PEOPLE, WE COULDN'T
FORESEE THIS 20 YEARS?
WE COULDN'T PREPARE FOR THIS?
IF YOU FOLLOW THAT EQUATION, WE
PROBABLY WOULD HAVE KILLED MORE
TALIBAN WE DIDN'T WAGE A WAR, W
WERE BABYSITTING.
WE DIDN'T WAGE A WAR, WE WERE
TRYING TO KEEP THE PEACE IN I
THINK THAT'S WHERE WE ARE NOW.
THOUGH I SOUND CYNICAL AND I'M
SKEPTICAL, BUT I'M A LITTLE MAD
THAT EVERYBODY ASSUMED IT WAS
GOING TO COLLAPSE.
PEOPLE ARE SAYING I DIDN'T THIN
IT WOULD COLLAPSE IS QUICKLY AS
IT DID, BUT IT DID APPEAR TO
WAIT, EVERYBODY KNEW IT WOULD
COLLAPSE EVEN AFTER ALL THIS
TRAINING IN INTELLIGENCE?
DON'T GET MAD AT PEOPLE WHO ARE
HAPPY WE ARE LEAVING.
DON'T CALL THEM QUITTERS OR THA
SOMEHOW THEY'RE LETTING OTHER
PEOPLE DOWN.
THERE JUST AS DISGUSTED AS
EVERYBODY ELSE ABOUT THAT.
WE'RE DISGUSTED AT HOW THIS
TURNED OUT, BUT IT'S NOT BECAUS
WE WANT TO LEAVE THAT BAD, WE
JUST WANTED THIS DONE CORRECTLY.
BY THE WAY, WE WERE TOO BUSY.
THINK ABOUT ALL THE STUFF WE
TALK ABOUT ON THE SHOW.
WE WERE TOO BUSY TALKING ABOUT
COMMANDER WHO WAS REPRIMANDING
AN ANTIRACISM BOOK TO HIS TROOPS
.
WE HAVE ANOTHER THE PC
RECRUITMENT ADS.
WE WERE SO OBSESSED DEBATING
TRENDS IN THE MILITARY THAT WE
STOPPED PAYING ATTENTION ABOUT
WE SAT HERE IN WHEAT OBSESSED
OVER JANUARY 6, RIGHT?
WE OBSESSED OVER THIS WHITE
SUPREMACY THAT'S EVERYWHERE.
KNOW, WE HAVE THE TALIBAN AND W
HAVE THE TERRORIST RIGHT THERE
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN NOW WERE AL
UPSET?
WHERE IS YOUR SOLUTION?
>> I HAVE BEEN ON THIS FOREVER.
>> I'M TALKING FOR MYSELF.
>> A COUPLE OF THINGS.
SO I FIND WITH THE SPEECHES THA
I WANT TO TAKE ELEMENTS OF IT I
REWORD THE ORDER.
AND MAY BE THAT JUST MEANS LATE
IN LIFE I WOULD BE TO BE A
FEATURE WRITER, BUT THERE WAS A
LOT INNATE THAT I WANTED TO HEA
INCLUDING THE BUCK STOPS WITH ME
.
>> THAT CAME AFTER THE BLAMING
OF EVERYONE ELSE.
>> AND THAT IS I THINK WHAT
DEMOCRATS IN SUPPORTERS OF THE
PRESIDENT IN HIS FOREIGN-POLICY
POSITION HAD REALLY WANTED TO
HEAR WHICH AS I DO TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY.
I THINK IT WAS THE RIGHT CHOICE
BUT IT ULTIMATELY FALLS.
YES I MIGHT BE THE FOURTH
PRESIDENT THAT HAS OVERSEEN THI
CONFLICT I THOUGHT IT WAS A
SMART LINE TO SAY I'M NOT GOING
TO PASS THIS ONTO A FIFTH
PRESIDENT BECAUSE 70 MARK WANTS
OUT OF AFGHANISTAN.
>> WE ALWAYS SHOULD SAY, BUT DO
YOU UNDERSTAND UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE IS IT THE TERROR ATTACK
WOULD CAME FROM THERE, WOULD IT
BE WORTH LEAVING?
>> I UNDERSTAND, I THINK THE
IDEA IS PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO BE
SUBJECT TO A TERRORIST ATTACK,
BUT WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO MANAGE
SOMETHING LIKE THIS AFTER TWO
DECADES IN GETTING TO KNOW THE
PEOPLE SO WELL.
SO THERE WAS ONE THING THAT HE
SAID THAT STUCK OUT TO ME WHICH
WAS OUR GOAL WAS NEVER
NATIONBUILDING.
AND THAT IS NOT TRUE.
OUR GOAL WAS NATIONBUILDING OR
AT LEAST IN PIECEMEAL IN IS
DRIFTED OUT BECAUSE WE WANTED T
BUILD THRIVING SOCIETY IN
DEMOCRACY SO WOMEN LIKE THAT
POOR AFGHAN REPORTER THAT HAD
THE MOST POIGNANT MOMENT OF THE
BRIEFING WHERE SHE SAID SHE PUT
OF HER MASK AT HER HOME FLAG ON
IT IN SHE SAID WHERE IS MY
PRESIDENT IN SHE WAS TALKING
ABOUT THE AFGHAN PRESIDENT HE
LEFT YESTERDAY AND WE DON'T KNO
WHERE HE IS.
AND, WE DID, AND I BELIEVED IN
IT, TRIED TO CREATE A SAFE PLAC
FOR MINORITIES IN AFGHANISTAN,
FOR WOMEN TO THRIVE THEY HAVE A
GOOD JOB, TO NOT BE SUBJUGATED
TO THE WHIMS OF THEIR HUSBANDS,
ET CETERA.
AND I THINK THAT WE NEED TO TAL
ABOUT THAT MORE BECAUSE I'VE
BEEN LOOKING AT WHAT THE
ESTABLISHMENT IN SAYING WHICH I
THAT THIS FOREIGN RELATIONS,
PEOPLE PUT OUT A LOT OF IDEAS
THAT I GENERALLY AGREE WITH AS
MODERATE, AND THEY ARE SAYING
THIS IS NOT BINARY, IT'S NOT OU
OR INCOME IT'S HOW WE GET OUT
AND NO ONE DISAGREES ABOUT THE
OUTCOME IS JUST THE WAY WE GET
THERE.
I DIDN'T HEAR DETAILS WE HEARD
22,000 MAY BE PEOPLE CAN COME
HERE.
THERE ARE DEFINITELY 22,000 WHO
WANT TO COME HERE.
OUT ARE WE GOING TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR WEAPONS DON'T END UP
THE TALIBAN'S WEAPONS?
THERE WAS NO GUARANTEE OF THAT
AND THAT IS THE SCARIEST THING
NOT JUST IN TERMS OF THE AIR
FLEET, BUT ON THE GROUND FOR IT
TO YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS SCARIER?
TO GIVE THE PRISONS CONTAINING
ISIS, AL QAEDA, TALIBAN, WIDE
OPEN.
I DON'T KNOW WHY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AGREED TO THE
5,000, THAT'S ALSO SOMETHING
PRETTY BAD.
YOU'VE BEEN BUSY CAN WE JUST GO
OFF WORK, LET'S WATCH.
>> THE PRESIDENT DID NOTHING
THAT WAS INEVITABLE THAT THE
TALIBAN WERE TO CONTROL OF
AFGHANISTAN HE THOUGHT THE
AFGHAN NATIONAL SECURITY FORCES
COULD STEP UP AND FIGHT BECAUSE
WE SPENT 20 YEARS, TENS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TRAINING
THEM, GIVING THEM THE BEST
EQUIPMENT, GIVING THEM SUPPORT
OF U.S. FORCES FOR 20 YEARS
PRETTY GOOD WE'VE SEEN THAT
FORCE HAS BEEN UNABLE TO DEFEND
THE COUNTRY IN THAT HAS HAPPEN
MORE QUICKLY THAN ANTICIPATED.
TAKE IT THEY GOT TALKING POINTS
DOWN.
WE CAN ANALYZE HOW WE GOT HERE
AND I THINK ONE HAS TO BOOKS
COMING OUT NOW THE TALKS ABOUT
OUR MISSTEPS IN AFGHANISTAN, BU
LET'S TALK ABOUT NOW.
RIGHT NOW, I HAVE NEVER SEEN A
SITUATION LIKE THAT IN THE
AIRPORT IN MY LIFE.
RUNNING IS FAST AS YOU CAN ON
THE TARMAC WITH THE BIGGEST LEA
I'VE EVER SEEN IN YOU HAVE
HUNDREDS IF NOT THOUSANDS OF
AFGHANS DYING TO GET IN.
THEY JUST SHUT DOWN THE AIRPORT
TILL THEY SECURE IT OR UNTIL TH
MARINES ARRIVED.
HOW DO YOU SOLVE THE PROBLEM?
IF THE TELE- BAND STARTS MOVING
ON THE AIRPORT, WHAT DO WE DO
THEN?
IN THE 2500 WAS TOO MANY, WE GO
NINE NOW.
>> ALL GOOD QUESTIONS.
ONE PIECE ABOUT THE TRANSLATOR,
THE INTERPRETERS, IT WASN'T THA
THEY WANT TO COME TO AMERICA.
THEY WERE PROMISED THEY WOULD
COME TO AMERICA.
IT WAS LIKE IF YOU ARE WILLING
TO HELP US WE WILL KEEP YOU IN
YOUR FAMILY SAFE.
THAT WAS THE REASON SOME OF THE
ARE DESPERATELY RUNNING.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW IF WE HAVE
THIS, BUT THERE IS A PHOTOGRAPH
OR YOU CAN SEE OF INSIDE THAT
PLANE IN I THINK THE AMERICAN
PILOTS THAT WERE ABLE TO GET
THAT PLANE OFF THE GROUND, THER
WE'RE ABOUT 600 PEOPLE, THEY
STRAPPED PEOPLE TO THE FLOOR
BECAUSE THERE WEREN'T ENOUGH
SEATS.
IN A WAY THEY DID WHAT THEY CAN
BUT I GO BACK TO YOU SHOULDN'T
HAVE TO DO THIS KIND OF
EMERGENCY IF THE DECISION WAS
MADE IN APRIL, AND ON THE
INTELLIGENCE, REMEMBER FOR
MONTHS WHAT HAS BEEN HAPPENING.
DOD DOD, ABOUT THREE MONTHS AGO
LEAKED TO THE MEDIA THAT THEY
HAD OFFERED TO THE WHITE HOUSE
THE CAPABILITY TO DO A BIG
AIRLIFT IN THE WHITE HOUSE SAID
NO THANK YOU.
IN THE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
KEPT LEAKING TO THE MEDIA OR
TELLING THEM, THIS IS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
AND THAT'S WHY THEY THINK THAT'
WHY THEY KNEW BECAUSE THE
INTELLIGENCE WAS TELLING THEM.
NOT ONLY THAT, THEY WERE TELLIN
US.
IF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SHOULDN'
HAVE TO GO MANAGE THE PROCESS.
THE PROCESS SHOULD BE MANAGED B
THE WHITE HOUSE ITSELF.
>> WITH THE KEEP SAYING IS TRUM
WAS GOING TO PULL OUT IN THEY
SAID THE DEFENSE DEPARTMENT WAS
ROLLING.
THEY WERE PERSUADING HIM.
THERE WE'RE PEOPLE THAT WERE
TRYING TO PERSUADE HIM IN A LOT
OF CASES THEY WERE UPSET ABOUT
SYRIA.
HE WANTED TO PULL ALL THE WAY
OUT OF AFGHANISTAN HE PAUSED NO
BECAUSE THEY WON, BECAUSE HE
LISTENED.
SO GREAT, I KNOW YOU HAVE TWO
MORE PAGES, SO WHAT ELSE.
>> KNOW, YOU ASKED WHAT CAN BE
DONE.
I THOUGHT IF YOU WATCHED THE
FIVE, I OFTEN USE THE PRISON OF
TWO IDEAS.
I THINK WE PROBABLY, BIDEN
MISSED AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REDEFINE THE MISSION IN THEY AR
NOT GOING TO FIGHT, WE DON'T
FIGHT, BUT WE CAN REDEFINE OUR
ROLE.
SO WE ARTERRA CONTROL.
WE'RE NOT IN A WAR, WE TALKED
ABOUT THIS BEFORE, WE ARE TERRO
CONTROLLED.
IT'S LIKE PEST CONTROL, ITS
MAINTENANCE, IT'S FOREVER.
>> BUT THAT DOESN'T WORK GREAT
IF YOU'D REDEFINE IT IN PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THAT IT'S AN ONGOING
THING.
YOU'VE GOT TO CLEAN IT COMMIT
YOU'VE GOT TO CLEAN IT UP
PERIODICALLY.
THAT'S A LOOK AT THIS.
SOMEONE NEEDS TO MAKE THAT CLEAR
.
WE'RE NOT INTERESTED IN WARS.
I AGREE WITH YOU, I THOUGHT THE
FIFTH PRESIDENT THING WAS
SUPERSTRONG, BUT HE WAS MISSING
THAT NEXT PART WHICH IS THIS IS
WHAT WE DO ABOUT TERROR.
>> IN THAT ENTIRE SPEECH HE SAI
LET'S TALK ABOUT HOW WE GOT HER
AND HE STARTS WITH THE INVASION
OF AFGHANISTAN.
THAT WAS NOT THE BEGINNING.
I WOULD'VE ADDED THAT LINE IN
THERE.
WELCOME WE'RE ABOUT TO HAVE THE
ANNIVERSARY.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE FAMILIES WHO
HAVE SPENT 20 YEARS WITHOUT
THEIR LOVED ONES ALSO THE
VETERANS WHO HAVE SPOKEN VERY
MOVINGLY OVER THE PAST FEW DAYS.
THE GOLDSTAR WIDOWS.
THEY ARE LIKE NO, ACTUALLY WE
REMEMBER THE WHOLE PHRASE OF
NEVER FORGET DIDN'T START IN
OCTOBER WHEN THERE WAS THE
INVASION OF AFGHANIST